In an attempt to finally get rid of SCP-682,
the Hard to Destroy Reptile, the SCP Foundation
considered leaving it inside SCP-3008, the
Infinite IKEA, and just letting it be their
problem for a change.
How do you think it worked out?
The Foundation sealed 682 into a box and sent
it inside of 3008 with an unmanned drone.
There was no response for 24 hours, at which
point, eighteen instances of the malformed
IKEA staff exited the building, each one carrying
a large box stamped with the IKEA logo.
They set these on the ground and then headed
back inside.
Inside of each of these boxes was a living
part of SCP-682, and like all things that
come out of an IKEA box, 682 had trouble correctly
putting itself back together.
Thankfully, this granted the Foundation time
to reestablish containment before SCP-682
had the chance to properly regenerate.